just felt very like magical and fantasy
and very like disney
our first look of camila cabello as
cinderella just dropped and it has a
singing
salah
on thursday amazon revealed two photos
of camila in the disney classic
in one image the actress is seemingly
singing while wearing what we can
only assume is a gown fit for a ball so
this is love
in the second shot the singer and
co-starred nicholas gallazine who plays
the prince charming are likely at the
ball itself
for me it's a dream come true but it's
worth pointing out that this pick
is totally giving us senorita vibes see
the resemblance
anyways this will be camila's acting
debut
et spoke with actress in 2019 about how
involved she will be
in the music for the disney classic
super involved
i'm writing songs for it and um it's
like a really collaborative effort to
make putting the movie together so is
that kind of insane to know that you
just put out an album and then we're
gonna get
more camilla music cause i'm excited
about that i'm so excited and
kay cannon is the director she's
absolutely incredible and
and so talented and just i think the
whole team is like it's such a joy so
i'm excited excited for the opportunity
it's really amazing and director kay
cannon is taking on the musical movie
with one
major plot twist no villains no no no
back in september k wrote reveling the
time i have left shooting with cinders
camila cabello
and her not evil stepmother idina menzel
i just surround myself with good
projects if i can and
it's something i i'm it sort of
encapsulates all the different
facets of who i am as a performer and
it's just exciting also starring in the
upcoming live-action film
billy porter the actor spoke to et about
playing the iconic role of cinderella's
fairy godmother
i got one big scene i come and slay
blow the roof off the joint and then i
get to go home so
and you always remember that character
the fairy godmother
she dresses she dresses the girl for the
ball
darling so i get to be that it's amazing
i'm looking forward to it
you